hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play the
things in that the night okay I was
informed that there is a key in this
area that I have overlooked somewhere
where there's a fireplace or something
like that
either way it's here I know it's here so
now I can find it so not here not here
not here okay I it's in one of these
rooms there is indeed a fireplace ah and
here nope
okay I must have checked that this one
someone said something if you guys lied
to me I'm going to be very upset and
there's not a thing I'm going to do
about it
that's a lock door okay so the other
door is up over yonder
oh maybe one of these I guess I kind of
asked him over
something down here nope yeah ah what's
that nothing it's nothing
get your ass out of the way so this is
not a place where did someone lie to me
did someone lied to me it's the first
room
that's the locked room all right what's
the dealio
oh no this is oh okay this who closed
that door I'll come on oh you got to be
joking me I thought someone said that
the key was in one of these fireplaces
is that I didn't check ah okay all right
let me think about this cuz I gotta
figure this out on my own using my brain
powers incredible incredible brain
powers I swear I swear someone said
something about that happening in that
way and then I missed it okay there was
something else saying about the thing
the guys in this room
but something to them I know there's
this book but I can't get at the book
it's just on the guy's chest so I don't
know what to do about that and there's
his penis oh what's going on what is
going on it's gotta be gotta be
something right ha yeah look off your
chest there's got to be something cuz
ever like I seriously do read all the
comments I swear I saw something this
deal nope apparently not
marque no likey it's my new catchphrase
marque no likey oh oh don't make me go
out and check
I'll make me exit the game Shack I don't
want to do that I don't want to do that
oh I'm gonna run out of oil just cuz I'm
trying to find it I really live in
darkness for a bit here
the real lab key does not work on the
door
I'm really really really looking in
these rooms like I'm not just jokey
jokey looking I'm like for serious
actually legitimately falls to the wall
looking like this is the most hard-core
looking like there could ever be if
there was a looking Olympics I would win
gold
there was a looking decathlon I would be
I would be in it to win it but now this
is just like oh man
okay I will find this and we'll find it
there must there must be a key in this
area there there cannot be anywhere else
it has to be here I'm looking at every
corner
I'm procedurally looking through every
corner every nook and cranny let's go up
if there's something up here up here
nothing over there nothing up here
nothing over there
nothing up nothing in the fireplace I've
already checked the drawers multiple
times nothing
Cherokee please move I will look in here
I will look in here I will look in here
aah and once again there's no all right
what was the deal there has to be a deal
ah so there must be
got away but get out - wait books what
about behind it okay anyway I guess I
would take some time to speak with you
guys about some stuff without the
channel I suppose I don't want to just
show the boring stuff I don't have
anything pulled up but um I guess I
could take a moment to explain that the
channel has been growing like exorbitant
ly and it's been just incredible what
we've been doing I've been in school
obviously I just started school so I
could tell deal with all the bad I am a
biomedical engineer as I said my little
v-log there so you can understand that
it's kind of a kind of a heavy load but
it's nothing I can hear maybe some up
here No
um yeah so and one thing about college
it just reminds me how alone I am [ __ ]
chibi sugar asked in my be log do I have
a girlfriend oh I can't find keys with
my eyes closed
I can't find keys through my tears
anyway one thing about nice about being
is colleges I call it there are a quite
a number of beautiful ladies out there
but none for me nothing a sad-sack let's
find this key I had a girlfriend I don't
know have less time for this right you
guys wouldn't want me to have less time
for this I almost wasted seven minutes
looking back through places I've already
checked for this thing exploit it go
through the ceiling and then I'm gonna
go up the other area I could probably
figure out an exploit faster than I can
find the key Oh
wiggle wiggle all right anyway so um
what I was getting on before about the
channel is the channel has been growing
incredibly fast considering how small
like we currently are we're about six
thousand three hundred services of the
reporting of this episode and it's been
going about up about a hundred a day
that's all thanks to you guys I mean I
can only do so much with making content
and I'm uploading videos and promoting
it myself on social media but it's it
really at the end of the day it's all
about you guys and you guys have done
beyond incredible in helping promote
like every share I know that some people
even perform my promotional contests
we're very very dedicated about sharing
my videos in I I just want to take a
moment to thank you guys personally for
doing that because like without you
without you I would be nothing and I
know that and I always recognize that so
I I understand it when you guys share
and like and comment and I don't ask for
it I I really don't I make a point not
to maybe I'll go into my reasoning of
explain why
I just wanted to say thank you for doing
that in the first place and show how
much I appreciate it anyway all right
don't can't find it King oh well it's so
sad I swear I've looked everywhere I've
looked everywhere every absolutely
everywhere there isn't a place I haven't
looked at behind everything I've looked
on top of everything I'm going to have
to go out and get some outside help
or else I'll be stuck forever
but first let me just take a gander
outside just for a little bit
I'm traped and I need to find the three
P's to shut down the electro waves those
are the worst kind of waves
any day now I got the first one down I
don't know where the third one's gonna
come up because if I find like the
second one through that hidden wall I
don't really know what's gonna happen I
don't know what's gonna happen I have a
loss
oh la la la and a little bit of lag
sorry about that but you guys should
realize that this is gonna happen in
this area
Oh lock now probably for the best
there were only death end what's in here
yeah maybe I've been looking these rooms
I mean it's always possible I'm not
doubting because I remember the last
time I came in through here I was kind
of a big baby about it and was kind of
crying and you know being totally
unmanned Oh see I missed that
who says I couldn't have missed okay you
gave me false hope you gave me false
hope that it is possible that I could
have found something else but it is the
way of the world
now I shall venture off this place is
still kind of Oh was there anything down
here doesn't pulsating action a winky
wink this dead guy how about this dead
guy with a knife in his back you got a
key of your butt No
all right then that was a lie on my way
back through the lag in the flames
somberly lag that's just low frame rates
but I'll keep they're all the same Boing
Boing Boing Boing I know I can find out
I will find out I will fight I'll find
define find hmm
gotta be it's gotta be in this area it
just has to be there's no other place
that it would be this area is built to
be focused in here to do this stuff for
this purpose right right and someone
said something about these two guys
fingers Oh fingers move oh that's so
creepy
what was the deal and why does that guy
have a Bible Isis maybe if I put a Bible
on the other guy's chest is that how
this works is that how this is gonna
happen actually that's probably a good
idea if there was a Bible in the other
room right I think so
so don't like the sounds those are just
regular birds who keeps closing that
door I look Bible esque
who keeps closing that door no this is
not a wife
ha ha just like that so perfect us an
ingenious plan cut off his head alright
ok well darn it I've run right out of
time making the most boring episode ever
in the entire world so I apologize for
that I thought I was coming into this
prepare I really did I thought I was
coming into this ready and rocking to
move on but apparently I'm a big fat
liar when it comes to that so I'm not
even gonna try to drag it on any further
this is gonna be cut short so thank you
all so much for watching it bearing with
me while I fail miserably ok anyway so
thank you all so much for watching and
as always I will solve this in the next
episode bye bye